Tại vì thật quốc ngày hôm nay, lòng thống em một chính thức mở quý trình bộ tổng thực kỳ nhận chỉ mới để kế nhợp ông Antonio
của Terrest, từ ngày bởi một tháng 1 năm 2020. Trong thư trung gửi cấn đơn thành viên,
hôi đông bảo an và trụ tịch đại hôm đông kêu gọi có cuo gia đe cửi em viên.
Nhìn mạnh trưa tưởng có phụ nữ dữ chức của này và để nghĩ u tiên xem sẽ có ở viên nữa,
đông thời bảo đam, tình đại giọc khu vực theo thủ tục.
Hối đông bảo an sẽ lửa trọn một tình viên để trình đại hôm đông bảo làm tổng thư kỳ thương mời trong năm 2020.
Quý định quý cùng phải được năm lưỡi thường trực gồm miếng, ngà, ăn, Trung Quốc và pháp bỏ phía hợp hợp.
Hẹn một số nên bật đã cùng khai những đình trình cường gồm cụt vào thống chiếc lên, bây giờ bà cá lẽ,
cụt vào thống thống cúst tại ríc ká bà rí bà cá ríc bà và thống thử kỳ cơ quan năng lượng miếng tự của tế,
hãy tìa đã ở nông thời lần nhàng vào giáo kỳ kiểu ở hành đi nà, ông Ruff-Rangosi,
của gồm giữa kỳ cơ quan năng lượng, giữa nước tục đầy cải tổng bộ mại lức đạo và tăng vai trò của các cú bực đăng phát triển trong hệ thống đứa nè của.